[Music]
so
so
yo
what's going on
realm last word
fireplace
good of it can't find what up we gonna
get everybody in here a little last
minute
you know shout out to he's on vacation
doing it up with the lovely wife but we
gotta do a show there's a lot of things
going on
a lot of this i will be doing live
live reactions i really didn't get a
chance to read the whole thing yet i
just probably read like a paragraph or
two so uh let me know my levels is good
i'm gonna get travis and screaming they
scream i see you in the chat what's
going on new rack we got mike's on his
side
no doubt what's up dude what's going on
oh david or rose you already know what
it is dj what's up
scream i'm gonna get you sinister what
up back for dad yeah we're gonna talk
about that scheisty little warlock
i arrow tighten my man what's going on
bro so look we're gonna get these people
in here we're gonna get travis you know
what i'm saying it's gonna be a very
different feel because it's live
reaction but um i will be back and we're
gonna get this campfire popping
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
all right
campfire what up
so we just waiting on screen is that a
little technical issue you know what i'm
saying taz what's going on hello aries
what's going on brother how you doing
man salute salute let me get you in here
get that mod on you right quick you know
what i mean so yeah we're just waiting
for on screen to get a little issue but
this gonna be a live
live bible reading of the 12 because i
didn't read finish it did you finish it
oh yeah i just finished it
i heard it spicy i heard it it's it's uh
it wasn't as much as i was thinking okay
okay yeah well
we'll get into it corey mosley what up
these cake skills h town what up oh you
ate the buffalo wild wings watching us
respect respect
so yeah we gonna give all my man a
little bit yo
that's hilarious wait till y'all see
travis's background it's gonna be
hilarious yeah titan you're gonna be
messy with that yolton man i only want
to talk to you about the fusion mods and
you already know we're gonna get into it
but anyway
i will see you guys in a bit as we wait
for will help screen
be right back
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
lovely
[Music]
all right
and we are live the last word with thai
guy travis and special guest today but
before we even get into that shout out
to the cheetah ibontis he was he's in
the sand he's in the beaches of sandro
pay i seen the feet up saying everything
was looking good brother enjoy your
vacation we're gonna hold it down it was
a crazy week already and destiny a lot
to talk about before i get into that
let's get into my co-host the man the
myth the legend mcclunkey himself ty guy
travis how are you doing sir my clunky
and let me just open the show by
dabbing
on locked music oh
that's a savage background bro
a little finally i love it
you
no i can and i will it's actually in a
bungee tradition to be doing so so there
we go
no no no turn your level up just a
little bit just slightly you got it man
slightly and of course no stranger to
the campfire probably his third or
fourth appearance
good friend to the realm met through
ibontis and now a clan mate
my man the legendary youtuber will help
scream how we do it sir i'm doing good
man thanks for having me back i'm really
excited to be here with
uh travis it's been like i've been
watching you guys for the last i mean
i've been watching forever but since
he's been making like common occurrences
on the show i have been very excited to
not only talk destiny with them but also
uh you know maybe
oh man they all see all right
we're going to put a cap on this star
wars talk now
is there anything you guys want to get
over the system in the star wars
universe before we get into this last
word this time we had a really long
discussion about the sequels and the
prequels and we kind of we kind of got
all the baseline off of our chest so
i'll just yeah i'll just say you know
how you how you enjoying bad batch
what's what's been up man you know i
haven't actually had the chance to watch
bad batch yet um i was kind of
watching a few other things
and then like that was sort of one of
those things that i was saving for like
when i had a chance to just
did all the episodes come out for it all
at once are they kind of releasing them
and like no no they're doing it week by
week but
is that like it's kind of a show it's
kind of a slow show i don't really know
why the show exists to be honest it's
sort of like an additional season of the
clone wars after all the cool stuff has
happened with characters you've never
met for the most part and so
um there's been some highlights but like
my review is that it's just like it's
just an okay show like they need to they
need to do something new i think i think
we've had enough of the clone wars
personally okay yeah i might wait to
watch it all at once like just yeah
i guess that i guess that's a way to
live your life but anyway
uh we're here to talk about destiny so
that's right all right all right
so jeff man let's get right into it man
obviously it's been a big week we know
we got to 12 we got a lot of stuff
discussed there but a big event happened
this week so uh let's get into it man i
tried to let you set it off man uh
an override mission a special override
mission happened i want to get you was
it special
yeah uh the override actual mission i
was pretty like okay well the location's
cool they're using a location but it's
on you know it's in the last city that's
kind of cool um but
the actual activity i was like all right
more override but i will say the added
story and the context and knowing what
was happening made that override way
cooler i actually wanted to participate
in every part of it rather than going
idle for you know certain bits of it and
all that so that was pretty cool um and
yeah we we finally got a lot of answers
a lot of stuff happened most of it off
screen yes first of all this happened
off screen watch me
death uh you kind of hear her screaming
uh like a wimp and then she disappears
but uh yeah she
by the way yes if i could just take a
moment to say that i was completely
right about this i think i said it on
this show or maybe it was on fire team
chatter both but basically when she was
saying oh i can see into the future it's
bad i said look i've seen a lot of time
travel movies whenever somebody who's
appearing to the future says that
they're always the person who's going to
cause the future that they're imagining
and that is exactly what happened like
verbatim so
uh yeah
extremely um predictable sort of outcome
but uh yeah i'm just glad she's dead
look at her that's the that's what she
deserves
before i get this girl i want to ask you
a question um
do you have the gun i believe it's a smg
it's a future war call smg something
with something variable with an s
stochastic variable the chat may know
what i'm talking about if you read the
lore fees it said it it's her flavor
text and it's like sometimes there's a
variable you can't account for in the
futures or something that you predict
it's kind of fitting that that
there it is the iron yes the stochastic
variable look a little good shout out to
logan shout out to the iron titan yeah
like i thought it was like fitting it
was like poetic justice on that so i
wanted to get you your vibe on on that
whole thing yeah it it strikes me as
incr like you would have to be
incredibly stupid to a
like you work with time travel and you
haven't seen this coming like like has
she never seen a movie where time travel
is involved or like talk to anybody
who's used time travel it's like such an
obvious outcome and apparently she's
like the sage of like seeing the future
but she didn't see any of this coming so
it's it's like hilariously stupid of her
to like not have have gotten that that
this was gonna happen especially given
the flavor text that kind of shows she
knows it and then secondly the fact that
she was dealing with this vex stuff and
a apparently the vanguard was just chill
about it they were like oh yeah she just
uses vex tech like that's her thing and
that she didn't think that opening a
portal uh that a vex gateway inside the
city was gonna have any sort of negative
results so like thank god she's dead
because this lady's a liability and uh
yeah that's my thoughts on it but i was
really surprised with some of the other
stuff that they did they they confirmed
the osiris thing which i mean at this
point we kind of all knew um they showed
the uh the the harpy the the allied
heartbeat again which we haven't seen in
a while yeah i think i think we i think
we saw that guy in d1 or oh
maybe he's shown up more recently are
the rumors with with asher mir being
some type of connection yeah that it's
got astro mirrors like we actually did
see it in b1 though that that that that
harpy has like super og roots um but
yeah there there's a theory that
um
that
that ashramer is like his consciousness
is inside the vex but i don't really
understand that because the harpy has
existed like before
um but i'm sure there's like some weird
time travel you can explain anything in
destiny and just go oh yeah there was
time or something and then and then all
the people will be like alright yeah
that makes sense that checks out um
so yeah there's that and then the final
one was the fact that the factions are
gone which i tweeted this this morning
i tweeted this morning
so i guess no return of faction rallies
huh like i guess that's not happening
wasn't that like asking for factions to
be involved and bungie's answer was just
nah we're doing the exact opposite like
we're just gonna get rid of them
completely i thought it was genius
scream that they narratively wrote
factions out of the lore and in the game
like that is hilarious to me they're
done forever yeah it was a little it was
a little forced in some of it like dead
orbit makes sense because they've been
talking about leaving forever so they
could have had that happen at any time
future war cult makes sense because they
suck and like they shouldn't be a
faction anymore uh but the fact that new
monarchy was a involved and then fled
neither of those things really makes
sense and i say that as a new monarchy
guys
let's go oh we all want to get they got
the best shades let's be real let's be
honest i think i wore my new monarchy
yeah yeah yeah i was on the show
yeah i i love new monarchy but it
doesn't really make sense because a
i don't understand why they would be
involved in the conspiracy and even if
they were they they clearly weren't as
that fall as future workforce and b the
fact that they would leave with dead or
but seems completely completely against
what their tenants are yeah yeah their
tenants like we stand and defend the
the towers so it doesn't really make
sense on a lot of levels they that one
feels shoehorned but at least dead orbit
future work no longer being around makes
sense and so um it'll be interesting i
guess we don't have any uh i guess we
don't have any future weapons or shaders
from those factions and they're just not
going to have a role which kind of makes
me a little sad to be honest i i was
like a big future sorry not a future
world called god now i was a big new
monarchy guy so um
it feels like the destiny universe is
getting
smaller all the time whether it's
planets disappearing or characters dying
or factions leaving we're sort of uh
getting really
close with with the things that we have
left and uh yeah i guess i guess it's an
opportunity to introduce new stuff but
i've talked enough this was a very
interesting epilogue
i'd love to hear your thoughts on it
well yeah let's get screen man scream
man what you thinking obviously
the end close of the season you know big
story beat lakshmi you know the whole
bit you know what was your thoughts on
the mission the structure and the the
lore implications
well first of all i like to say that um
my favorite tweet from the last two days
was
uh how did akora have
two nova bombs
uh that was
i think it's a question that needs
answering to be honest
as a warlock you know as somebody who is
probably the only person who runs blink
anymore
shout out to the nova warp though she
had the nova warp little at the end of
the night i don't think we've ever seen
you never seen a busta nova walk out
right in time for the sandbox change
yeah the uh that was really interesting
actually you know what this isn't even
the first time we've seen the vanguard
use two supers maybe they have a special
exotic
vanguard exotic that gives them because
we saw it with kate he did golden gun
knives right yes correct correct good
tease group
um yeah i mean overall i think
you know with the narrative there's
always there's you know me i have like
one thing that i have i've had in my
mind for about like two three two years
now and i'm like
i'm still convinced that that's what
we're heading towards before before you
can't even set that up you have to
inform the audience you have to form
trav
what the theory and before you do that
shout out to gabriel forte with the five
dollar signature what's up shout out to
the hunter gang for having instant turn
rate on console like pc it took a few
days to get used to 10 sensitivity i
wonder how long for 20. we gonna get to
that bro
forte yo if you was ever going to come
up maybe to get away from work we'd have
we need hunter representation today but
continue on your theory scream educate
travis what you think's gonna happen all
right well this is i mean it's a pretty
big uh shout out to cb gray spin foil
hattie yes uh
thing but i think it makes certain sense
maybe it doesn't in
in my you know narrative mind i always
think like
there's got the the enemy always needs
to be like right in front of us like the
ultimate like enemy always needs to be
kind of someone that
one that you don't suspect but also
somebody who isn't always an enemy like
you know like they they can kind of go
back and forth right so i've i've
believed for a long time
that
is actually our
uh greatest enemy because
is she what you say
he's been running with this i don't
agree with you
and there's reasons for me to there's
reasons to maybe think that there's
probably reasons not to i mean i've
certainly heard a lot of arguments but
nothing
has been introduced in the narrative
that has necessarily counter you know
contradicted that it's kind of a big you
know a big lack of proof is proof it's
relatively what you're going with well
my the theory breaks down to that the
dreaming city is a time like
it's a time bubble it's like a
singularity and she's using that to
subvert the sword logic of
the of the hive which is that where they
get the power from but they need to
constantly feed it but if you had a time
loop the time loop itself could
essentially feed the store logic and
allow you to slowly over time
progressively gain power without having
to actually do anything and the way that
the reason i think that
that's a time loop is because there is a
narrative point where
um
uh oryx
yeah or orcs um
basically he
gifted a vex mine that had been created
specifically to destroy the hive to
savathun
and that and the vex obviously played
with time travel so it all goes back to
time travel slowly by the end and the
very first uh awoken
became awoken because they encountered
they were actually humans they were [ __ ]
that was i can't remember exactly where
they were but they were somewhere in
this yeah maybe just they were they're
out by their um jupiter
wherever they hang out they're right in
the in the asteroids called the neck the
next whatever yeah
and they encountered a singularity a vec
and it's not
said whether or not you know where it
came from or what but they encounter a a
singularity sort of like reminiscent of
a black hole they get sucked in
immediately become the awoken okay so
what i believe was that that singularity
was
um basically vex tech corrupted by the
hive which we've seen now we've seen
like high vex sort of hybrid stuff and
this was i thought of this long before
we ever knew there was going to be a
he's been on this i give you credit
you've been on this for a long time long
before so even some of the stuff that
we've seen for the coming seasons has
kind of played into that somewhat
um
so my thought was that they could they
the uh sabathune created a singularity
using vex tech to subvert the sword
logic she created that singularity that
a
bounded to the first awoken because
those were the first awoken that
encountered the first humans that
encountered it became awoken and she
like put a piece of herself
into
um one of those
you know initial proto
and she's been sort of using that as a
way to
yeah slowly gain power over time which
is why it's on a three-week cycle okay
which is though you know every three
weeks we either you know darkness either
consumes it or we defeat it either way
it plays into her narrative into the
loop right no doubt so with everything
being said now with the story the
epilogue
oh suspicious
the whole like where are you at now with
this whole picture
well i think
i mean the
the whole osiris-like sus thing uh
he they when you when they would used to
show like those um you know cut scenes
of the uh
the nine
you know and because they kind of have a
point here too but they're sort of like
they talk about the game you know the
game that's being played yeah you know
cryptic and that's sort of i guess the
good versus evil which is that you know
there's the you have the traveler which
is just
constantly creating stuff and then you
have
the darkness which is sort of like the
worms that infected the proto-hive which
are kind of
i guess as close to we know of what the
darkness like physical embodiment of the
darkness is there's actually a different
um version of that that i'm just not
aware of maybe you could tell me but
that's as far as i know is like that's
as close to the physical embodiment of
the darkness that we know which is
basically just the constant need to
consume so one always creating
another one taken taking plan it's
taking destiny
so that's the game and they're not
really involved they're just overseers
and their interest
is that they have
you know that there's some players in
this game that are sort of figuring out
ways to subvert that okay which in
the case of savathune would be the idea
that she can
um
she doesn't have to destroy while still
gaining all the power of the destruction
right whereas like
uh osiris could also be one of those
players they talk about three
specifically okay and the i've always
thought that it was marisov
osiris and
the um
uh and the drifter was the other one
okay because
once they've all sort of taken like they
kind of have a good side but they're
right and they have right
so based on what you're saying
you feel that is legit osiris
i think it's legit osiris and i think
the reason that he's sort of detached is
because he's seeing
you know just like uh
somebody who's seen a movie play out a
million different ways right just
observing this one and seeing if this is
like the ultimate timeline to follow
that let me let me push back on one
thing what do you say
to the people who read that lore card
where it appears to be savathun talking
and it appears to be
savithu talking about maintaining a form
a disguise that it's very hard and that
people in the tower are coming up to her
it and it's a struggle to maintain the
form because the prevailing theory is
that that is her
imitating osiris in a fleshly form
whether or not he's dead or his body is
possessed by something he's somewhere
else but that lore card seems to
substantiate a lot of people whose
theory feels that this is severe through
imitating that what do you say to to
that lorkhart i say it could be because
this is a theory but interestingly
enough there was also one other person
in the epilogue that was kind of out of
place and that's amanda holliday and
you never see you know i'm not saying
that sabathune is one person it could be
you know there could be many forms of
this individual the the interesting
thing about marasav is that you haven't
seen her in a long time and we remember
getting all those sort of uh weekly
right the last i remember seeing her we
was in her throne thing right she she
wasn't there but there was the hourglass
and then we went up to it and we saw
aldrin's awakening into becoming
a a guardian right right so continue so
oh by the way to actually luka finally
super chat titan gang i see you i see
you we're going to get to that
salute to luca though that's the clan
so there could be uh there could be a
different like split form because
obviously if mars if if anybody is
sabbath in disguise then they could
probably use more than one disguise
so
there's always kind of the element that
have we ever seen somebody and you know
two people in the same place at the same
time there's a lot of people who we
haven't seen in the same place at the
same time
um
if i don't believe it's osiris though
okay
just doesn't seem to fit the narrative
arc i think he could be
uh
yeah i think like i said he could either
be following a specific timeline and
he's just seeing it play out i think
being the fact that he's um one of the
only people that we know that can kind
of go back and forth in time other than
the vex right that he uh maybe he's on
sort of on the trail that kind of thing
like okay but
but it could be
no don't look this is way this is where
you are yeah not to say when you when
you're ready yeah this is this is very
spin foily like it is especially like
your background like you're in the dark
you just look like you're in like a
bunker somewhere planning for the end of
the world i'm telling you in four days
at 11 30 everyone will die uh
the uh i just i i honestly think
i would love it if if bungie
you know thought that far ahead and was
that committed to the story but i
honestly think would be that many levels
oh yeah i think he'd give a budgie two
credits credit that's about that i'm
like
daddy bro i just i just think like hey
bungie wouldn't do that because it would
confuse everyone right like if they have
this whole oh there's three betrayals
and one of them is mara and half of the
community would be like who is marsaab
and all that stuff and b it's like the
simplest solution is often the the
solution i think it's probably just
osiris and there's i have a lot of
questions about your theory i probably
shouldn't get into them because they'll
lead until like
like
you know like like just like a cliff
like just one that came to mind right
away is like why would mara save as
sabbath dune help kill uh oryx
sabathune's brother which he does in
destiny 1. i mean that
you could you could work into some some
ways there but like you you they never
really particularly liked one another
though
that is true but but part of the reason
she's coming after us is because we've
been messing with her family so i think
it's one of those things where it's like
only i can hate brothers
all right we're gonna stop the temple
let me get my thoughts on cause we
getting deep we got third eyes open we
got turbans with jewels on them look
yeah you can't
purchase everything i say with i'm a nut
that's so good that's the thing you can
use you can use every argument as like
further proof but like what if it goes
even more but like that is what
conspiracy theorists do and i just don't
think that like
uh i just don't think used that i don't
think it just doesn't sound like them
they've never done that i bet you it's
going to be like literally savathun just
comes out of the closet like ooga
that's that's like how stupid it's going
to be that's just my guess do you think
that you've been the bad guy the
i just honestly think it's gonna be that
simple it's gonna be like oh new bad
guys here somebody that you didn't see
and and maybe osiris will help kind of
be the harbinger of her return or
whatever but like
you know i just i really don't think
it's going to be like an
earth-shattering maybe i'm wrong they
killed off three factions today i was
like
to a mission so who knows but i just
want to be right because if something no
this this is your ultimate if you're
right yeah yeah
you're right it might be in the man on
the island to myself no respect respect
i'll get into it um look you know the
mission shot the attic he hit me up he's
like yo the mission's out you know
jumped in there um narratively you know
you hear you hear the pa and her talking
her talk and then you hear the scream
you go in there as you see travis's
background that was the first thing i
saw on the floor homegirl completely
body she's not making the tower great
again anymore she's not being
disrespectful to fallen
so yeah you know it i thought it was you
know obviously it's override but i like
the way it was handled where you come in
through i guess the city and then you
that botched the district where you did
the raid and stuff like that which is
pretty cool
i love the voice acting with uh myth and
saint saint trying to hold it down and
saying hey i mean it was a bit over the
top like you know you're my brother i'm
not gonna save you okay there's a little
extra but they got the point across
about unity you know
as far as aikora on the loudspeaker like
oh osiris come in
uh osiris
where are you i thought that was
hilarious you know say he was right
behind me you know kind of the whole bit
so that and then obviously him looming
over everything was very chilling was
very like yo what is up with dude that's
my boy but what is going on this is
super sus so that whole thing played out
i thought very well um you know shout
out to the little magic moment you know
you got uh i think it was um who put it
in shout out to pull tasks he said uh he
said amanda holiday coming in here with
a basic of chavarro with no respawns
she was riding down she came in you know
she's busting a gun or whatever you know
but i love the saint and yeah shout out
to def city i like the saint
and myth racks lil bond that that was
cool you know and then you go in there
you do it i didn't like the fact it was
kind of like a no-name boss at the end
of that override yeah and that was kind
of kind of took a little steam out of it
but look it was what it was they they
the mission was accomplished the only
thing i find interesting travis is after
all of this with osiris this bed has the
most cachet
ever because
cora is like well you know if he just
comes back to the tower and explains
himself he you know it'll be all good
like
literally he like he was the last person
right
incriminated with
right and using helping to use the vex
tech you know he's nowhere to be found
the city is completely invaded why is
this man not on trial for something like
that why what's up you know why it's
because he's done this before he he's
like the he's like the dad who like
always walks out and he's like
blow up this city though
he needs to blow off some steam i mean
he did betray the vanguard like
he didn't listen to the speaker because
the speaker got exiled yeah but because
of the speaker though that was a
different it wasn't like he brought
drama into the city and the city was at
it's you know about to die this was like
a a leadership philosophy thing i don't
agree with what you talking about i
think the vex are the real threat and
then the speaker like yo your teachings
are a little bit too off
he like basically raised a cult around
him who thought he was a god i'd say
that's pretty drama phil raised the code
they they infatuated with him in his
teachings yeah it'd be great try to stop
them at all that's what you're saying
yeah and then the second reason is that
two of the people who are essentially
the leaders of the vanguard have a soft
spot for him akora and saint 14. his his
lover so it's like true but but
zavala doesn't and i thought that's
interesting i thought the zavala in him
relationship was interesting because
like well they got the temporary exile
lifted initially right
and we know obviously
is boo thing we get that you know what
i'm saying but yeah akora we get the
history but i am surprised to your point
that zavala
kind of allowed him back into i mean
zaval has been sackless for like
six seasons dude the guy just doesn't
you can walk all over him at this point
think about all the stuff that's
happened that he's not okay with using
the darkness right like the whole war
mind awakening like everything that he's
against we just do anyway and then his
responses
very well but i you're right you're
right you're right you're going to be
getting a stern letter
you're right we came back using the
darkness you're right you're right dude
he literally like i i wouldn't like i
wouldn't put a stalking and stopping
everything at this point if sabbath dune
came on and killed everybody i could
just see him standing there at the tower
being like well i disagree with your
methods but um you know like he's not
going to actually do anything with this
guy so no respect for zavala i should be
the titan vanguard
so that was pretty much it you know
obviously my last question for you guys
a reference to it like the way they
ended it you know obviously he's nowhere
to be found you know the city we have
this memorial thing we got that going on
you know
do you guys think when do you guys think
the reveal for savithoon's gonna happen
do you think this plays on again all
through next season and osiris is gone
do you like where are you at trav like
with this whole when does the the big
aha
because the guard i mean the vanguard is
just so casual with this i feel yeah i
think it's probably
the exact thing that ebontas doesn't
want to happen where like
on august 24th we basically know what
the next season is going to look like in
terms of the big like reveal that's my
guess
and
i think that uh
yeah i think we find that out on the
24th and then i think season 15 maybe is
us working against osiris or they might
save that for the main one i don't know
if that would overshadow sabathune being
there physically but i could see season
15 being the
like osiris has officially betrayed a
season or like unraveling the mystery of
what's behind it but i think either way
we'll know how it ends before the
season's even over because because of
the trailers and the the advertising for
first season of the the witch queen
before i passed the screen your final
gut right now
is
osiris osiris or is that sabbath
masquerading for you trav what do you
think is going on
i think osiris is a puppet to uh
sabotage but i think it's him physically
but i think i think it's just you know
like apparently
part of the city is locked with her
because we hear
the city singing the sabbath song like
there's something going on there so i do
think there will be a big betrayal and a
big like sabbath is here and she's been
like way many steps ahead of us i just
don't think they're going to get like
super into the lore and be like imara
sab was actually like a original spawn i
just i really just don't think it's
going to be that level i think it's
going to be like
simple
yeah then you know maybe maybe we'll get
some human taken because she corrupted
uh people in the last city or something
like that you know what i mean like
there'll be some sort of like mob or
explanation for why she's even more of a
threat than uh oryx but yeah fair enough
sir and scream to your point obviously
we know what your theory is we know what
your stance is hold on we got oh gee
it's baby jesus with the five dollar
super chat it's going to end like game
of thrones and the white walkers yeah
yeah kind of simple yeah i feel you
going i feel you going yeah it's all of
all of our theories building up like
like game of thrones and then it just
turns out they're just bad zombies that
you kill one time yeah so it's gonna say
i called bran in season two
oh you did i did i called bran in season
two all right all right so look it
didn't happen the way i hoped because it
happened it was really bad narrative
structure towards the end of that show
but
it was still the same results so yeah
yeah
it'll be better in the books the books
are better the books were probably yeah
whenever it's really so to you so for
you now screen obviously we know what
theory is but i want to ask you about
the reveal of
whatever whether it be savithoon we know
which queen the 20 you know the 24th is
coming so it's like
do you think this is revealed then very
end with very end with its time for the
season that we know what's going on
what's happening no i think they're
going to reveal it then okay i think
they're going to reveal it
sorry
he hates that
dude it just it just makes sense
like yeah they got to build hype all
right so look i'll say my final thoughts
obviously i'm still
holding hope that my man is either under
duress
not dead
baby um
body form taken but i'm still going
wrong with the theory it's a fun i will
say this
as much as i'm an osiris fanboy there is
a part of me that says it is fun
watching this betrayal or whatever with
him in it because i think a lot of
people it added a little bit more spice
to the character because what the way i
liked him as this divine whatever a lot
of the rest destiny community did not
like him the way i liked him but in this
role it is fun to see people be like yo
he's suspect oh i like the energy
towards him they hate like so i kinda he
actually fits the villain role better as
much as i fanboy so salute to oh
suspicious in the whole thing and never
trust a warlock i think this is the
takeaway the main thing that you should
take away is warlocks are unreliable
uh easily corrupted
and
i mean yeah my man zavolo just sits
there and does nothing enough but at
least you can count on him to do nothing
thank you thank you scream
we salute to the titan delegation look
man you bear gotta go find out what's
going on with mommy say 14 need to go
find out with the bull thing what's
happening man what's happening go for it
i'm sure there will be some there's got
to be some sort of
uh at least nod to their relationship if
this goes out the way we think it's
going to be yeah that could get really
if again we're asking a lot for bungie i
agree with you try where
i think this is
i'm totally with you but what would be
dope if you really want to do the ad to
brute
the portrayal to saint and saint fine if
they really up it that would be fire
like yo i can't believe you the problem
is their relationship is basically eu
you know what i mean it's like
it's like not something that the average
player knows that's correct
might not waste they might not waste
time yeah yeah yeah
it's uh yeah
so i would love if they did like a thing
where like there was a mission or a lore
entry or something i'm sure they will do
that but i just don't see them making it
part of like the main narrative i don't
think we get a cut scene where he's like
osiris how could you i don't know
if i'm wrong i will be so happy but i
just at this point man no no i'm with
you i'm with you i'm with you on that
shout out to the irl titan safeway team
we'll buy you ice cream if you told him
you had a bad day osiris will give you a
lecture
warlock masturbate salute anyway moving
on so look we got a lot to cover a lot
going on in this game so obviously we
saw um i believe dmg had put the post up
initially kind of you know teasing those
mods that would be coming you know what
i'm saying so we saw a couple of them in
there we got that auto rifle you know
what i'm saying anti-barrier we got a
looks like linear fusion and regular
fusion
unstoppable
bow you know what i'm saying got bull
overload and then we got pulses with
unstoppable and
sidearms
unstoppable some people like them
again i mean the bow is actually the bow
and the fusion rifle are great i think
bow is so underrated in terms of like
yeah it's so underrated specifically for
that role what is it the barrier
breaking or yes with the oval especially
if you have the explosive head ones that
kind of count as a two and also we got a
shout out that i i don't think gets
enough credit when it came out during
battlegrounds was it tiku's definition
that's a nice one man that that whole
little mechanic but i just wanted to ask
you guys you know in general obviously
they also hinted with a whole little
clue about you know penn meyer than the
sword so that the sword is most likely
going to be the second overload to go
with arrows so
i'll give it to screen like with all of
these out here that we know how are you
feeling about these for the new champion
mods in general any eddie builds any
things that you got excited about
yeah uh i think it's going to be a fun
season specifically because there's like
we well we've never seen like a fusion
mod
so you know telesto is going to be oh
god oh god
um outbreak perfected is going down
this season's mods have driven me
absolutely up the wall like i mean
anybody who's out there who's been
trying to get a conqueror seal this
season
hates the glass way and never wants to
see it again i know
uh yeah sinister scene yeah
i think he's still trying i think he's
probably trying right now no no he got
it he put it up on twitter oh he tweeted
the whole he got his conqueror title he
put it up on twitter shout out to
podcasts
i see you continue
i see you what's going on
but yeah uh it's just
it's it's it's been rough like i
i really liked last season when we had
the sniper mod i think that
the best thing that they could have done
i love that
i don't like it when things get made
more difficult simply because you have
to use two primaries like i think you
should always be able in every single
strike to be able to use
how it's intended a primary a special
and heavy
um when you can't do that i'm just sort
of disappointed it makes me not want to
play the activity
um and also like
these you know the outbreak has been
i mean outbreak and celestia i mean
they've been around forever i never feel
like i get to use
that many exotics in the strikes like i
feel like you should always be able to
bring at least one exotic with you i
mean we you can use wither horde right
now which has been really good this
season but you don't get to use it all
the time and so there should always be i
think like two or three maybe four
exotics that you can bring with any
single build so
um i think that
i i don't know if i don't know if bungie
realized that maybe they made it a
little too uh i don't know just stagnant
this year when it comes to those um
champion mods but it seems like they're
definitely doing us a favor next season
with um with the ones they've announced
no fair enough fair enough let's uh
actually before i pass it to the track
any particular i know you said outbreak
perfected any other particular loadouts
that you're excited to maybe try besides
telesto and the obvious
um well there's
i'm curious if um what's the heavy bow
um oh leviathan's breath survivor's
breath yeah i'm curious to see how uh
that will work because that's
b i mean that that's like
probably i mean it's not the fastest uh
dps but it definitely is one of the
hardest single
again the only thing i t i remember last
time bowls were
overload and i remember using
leviathan's breath the fact that it had
the intrinsic unstoppable property
canceled out the overload so i don't
know if they they seem to be against
the exotics that have the intrinsic
ability to have an additional one with
the mod but we'll see we'll see and then
what's the other bow that's um
the special is it trinity ghoul yes it's
uh yeah part one the one that has like
crazy right yeah yeah that would be cool
to use too um i don't think that has an
intrinsic perk on it no you're right
you're absolutely right
so let's get trav man you see the mods
what were your thoughts on it and uh any
loadouts any things you're excited about
running with i know you got the sidearms
ready
yeah yeah that's me i don't know how
much i love sidearms uh no i i think um
i think it's kind of cool that we can we
can have a full load out of all of our
breaker you know all of our all of those
mods without having
um
[Music]
like basically we can do it all with
primary weapons right like there's bows
there's pulse rifles and auto rifles and
that will take care of all of your needs
it'll give you we've got the
anti-barrier on the auto
the unstoppable on the pulse rifle and
the overload on the bow i think that's
awesome so i'll probably just switch
between those but honestly i'm just most
excited about fusion rifles swords i
mean swords have always kind of like had
a role and if you're playing a really
high end activity it's not going to be
useful anyway like grand master you're
just not going to be able to use a sword
most likely i'm sure somebody will prove
me wrong but it probably is not the
easiest uh clear um and and yeah the
like fusion rifles just haven't had
their time in the sun i think so i'll
probably rock with
pulse rifle fusion rifle in the middle
slot maybe i'll do gn7 maybe i'll do a
sleeper simulant and my power supply
sleeve
yeah
so i'll probably do gene seven in the
special slot sleeper in the power slot
and then in my my uh my top slot i'll do
maybe not a rifle or a bow or something
like that so yeah just just to handle
all the all of the
sorry actually pulse rifle and uh and
and fusion rifles do the same thing
they're both uh unstoppable so yeah i'll
have to choose between those but yeah
you know it gives you some i feel like
this season's set up gives you a little
bit more freedom with how you do it yes
we're gonna have to continue to reset
our
uh artifacts to get the right mods that
we need and yeah all that annoying stuff
but yeah i'm definitely going to uh have
some fun with this one i'm also
wondering if uh vex method class will
count for the fusion right now think
about that technically it's an auto
rifle and a fusion rifle so can i put
both of those mounts and have it do both
roles
and i it's still a user rifle
technically i mean yeah it is a fusion
even though it shoots like an auto yeah
but right now it takes auto rifle mods
right as well as and they said they're
going to take fusion rifle mods in the
future so it would be interesting if you
could do both with one weapon but
i'm probably that's probably not going
to happen i'm just being uh but either
way i mean if you put that in your slot
and you equip the fusion rifle mod to it
you're getting unstoppable so that would
be amazing so there's just it just feels
like there's a little bit more freedom
than there was in other seasons where
there was like kind of a a way you had
to play in order to be competitive and
this one just feels like there's a
little more freedom so i'm happy with it
i still don't like this system to be
honest it's not fair shout out to dj or
something in the chat he said wilhelm
you're doing glassway carries right
after this right
he's trying to put in his clan request
for you right now
let the bear rest all right relax dj you
just got into the clan pleb he's one of
them
that's the fandom i love this clown
it's hilarious but look i mean as far as
this is concerned yeah i mean
i'm excited i like the uh the different
variations i'm thinking about how arbor
less might play out you know and
bringing that back as far as we're
having that unstoppable mind stuff like
that especially like grandmasters and
things of that nature see if that is
going to be in there sleep of course
travis you know how i feel so having
that out there to use that um there's
some cool um legendary linears i believe
it's uh of course his wrath i got a good
roll with that and i forgot the the
battlegrounds one i forgot the name of
it is um it's really cool so we're going
to see how the meta shifts there
obviously fusions are going to be lit we
know about the telescopes you know what
about young's i think i can't wait for
um no composure to see how that and um
plug one i believe you know to have that
to have those properties as well but i
gotta go back to all reliable um yeah
just see to see my man outbreak
perfected get get used again you know
because yeah it's gonna be consistent
and bowls and stuff like that so look
it's a fun thing i'm getting tired of
this sidearm unstoppable though i gotta
be honest again them getting kind of
sick they're like they don't know what
to do with the sidearm and they keep
trying to force it no one's jumping that
close
to the stop yeah like so they're kind of
trying to shoehorn it in just so yeah
usage goes up yeah so anyway so look we
got that going let's get into the shout
out to ireland i already know yo baby i
already know you're gonna go crazy
you're gonna go crazy infusion god bless
hopefully it doesn't break the game and
they have to shut it down again but you
think they'll get rid of this system in
which queen do you think they've had
enough
it's a good question right because at
some point
you know these
things i mean the only thing i think we
haven't really got is like machine gun i
feel like we haven't got a machine gun
and one of the ones we've missed i think
rocket launcher hasn't been there for a
while yeah yeah not not much yeah
there's a couple
that they still haven't really touched
but after a while this system is gonna
you know as far as redundant it's gonna
get redundant it's not gonna be a lot of
options so it'll be interesting to see
if they get rid of it do you think
scream they get rid of this system or
make major changes to the mod system i
mean they might just make it i
think rather than get rid of it they
just make it a season where they're just
all available
you know like every single mod is
available and they
maybe you know and it just becomes they
just become sort of a
um champions become essentially the same
thing as burns or shields and then they
maybe introduce something else uh
usually what they do but yeah
i think they should probably just like
if they were gonna keep the system
just have all the mods available and you
have to choose which one to equip like
there should be you know
a overload mod for all the weapon types
and you should just have to have that
one in your loadout if that's the way
you're playing
but you should be able to keep them all
but i just think the system like what
they're trying to do control the sandbox
and choose decide the way that you play
for you
it's really going to be
[Music]
to the experience if which queen comes
out and there's a certain set of weapons
you have to use like i don't want my
loadout to be decided for me when i go
and fight
you know what i mean like that's the
part i just think this whole
it needs to go the way of hopefully
look you're making a good point trav
because
as much there's a part of me that loves
to play differently right and to try
things i don't normally try and have
some joy with that right and i know i
did have fun with the grenade launcher
meta it was cool but then you're right
there sometimes we're just like yo i
just want to use what i want to use and
not be forced into this okay if i don't
play this way this season i am
completely not being effective and
efficient for the for my fire team or
the raid or whatever so i do understand
your point there and it's a balance
they're gonna have to try to navigate
you know so look we got a lot to get
into meaty meaty twab
shout out to uh iron tight he says the
luxury treat treatment coin it trademark
it
the
bungee we don't do that here cog no
doubt so look real quickly i'll just
glance over this part they did talk
about um fine tuning in reference to
chata forte who mentioned it earlier
controller sensitivity and traction and
the traction mod itself so they felt
that the traction mod uh was mandatory
for pvp on controller and unnecessary on
mouse and keyboard they felt to be more
appropriate as an accessibility option
rather than a balance joint players have
also felt maximum 10 sensitivity wasn't
enough for controller so they're making
some changes to controller input closer
to parity with keyboard and mouse so
they added a sprint turn speed scaler
option allowed value 0.3 to 0.8 removed
the traction mod entirely added
additional controller sensitivity
options 1 to 10 sensitivity is the same
as before 11 to 20 increases over that
and then they added an ads sensitivity
modifier so quick thoughts on controller
were you guys feeling this yay where you
at
yeah i play on max on controllers so i'm
wondering if i can get the 20
sensitivity down how much that would
mess up my game but i guess uh now's a
good time to test it out before cross
play happens because
it could potentially if you become good
at it make you competitive with a mouse
and keyboard i mean more than i already
am flexible
let's go
yeah yeah i mean we're gonna have those
guys in our lobbies especially since my
entire clan is on pc i'm probably gonna
play um you know a lot of of comp and a
lot of trials with them and i'm gonna
just kind of have to get used to having
those guys in my lobby so um yeah
absolutely scream cool yay
yeah i think it's good uh i you know one
of the things that i think is sort of
underrated when it comes to turning
speed is that is
yeah it helps you obviously you know
aim a little bit faster but the thing
that it actually helps you with a lot is
escaping like that's one of the things
no one really realizes is with when you
can turn quickly and you can just poke a
corner shoot and then immediately turn
like the quicker you can turn and scoot
away or slide away that's what allows
you to stay alive and that's like
one of the things that um you know when
i would play on uh
on pc it was just like i just felt like
it was
i actually find that the the crucible
experience on console is actually a lot
more fun
than pc for
maybe reasons that aren't really
associated with that specifically
but
i found that i was able to actually um
even though i could slay more on console
i was able to stay alive more on on pc
so
you know i like with cosplay coming in
it's going to be essential because those
guys
if you're on a mouse and keyboard
there's no way that anybody who's on a
controller is going to be able to i mean
even if you have a good shot those are
not named travis you mean those not
names right
he handles them but continue no i
honestly there's lots of people on pc
who uh who play on controller and and
just kick the the crap out of out of uh
mouse and keyboard player a lot of them
are in my clan which is why i'm just
like i don't really care about the mouse
and keyboard thing but
the
it's there's not parity between using
controller and pc and on console and i
think that's what this is trying to
address because using using controller
on pc is
far superior or at least easier than
using it on console so i think they're
trying to make it so that if you're
playing on controller no matter what
platform you're on it's sort of a equal
experience unless you're playing on uh
the dual shock 5 because that controller
has
it sticks located on the wrong part of
the controller but that's okay when it
comes to head shot accuracy on pc using
a controller too it's
way easier like you get like zero recoil
so yeah you know
apologies playstation nation for the
outburst of uh our co-host there or the
the slider the consistent dual i love
playstation but that controller is not
good for shooters i'm sorry but just the
staggered staggered sticks are the way
to go man though he died on it he died
no no so look i think we had agreement
there yeah i was actually surprised to
see this um i thought it's really cool
right right before cross play let's get
everything as closely aligned as
possible so yep that's all i got so
let's get into it meaty twap super
regenerating exotics this is a big one
so of course in bungee fashion they said
in some cases they feel that this could
trivialize the content or make it feel
like the only reasonable option to equip
for your build most of these changes
here to aim to standardize how these
exotics work and to place a cap on how
much super uptime they can grant by
themselves to offset these changes some
of the perks were reworked to be more
generous with their refund minimums so
let's get to it
shards of galinor increase the amount of
supers granted for hits but but total
super regain is now capped at 50 percent
ursa furiosa cap the amount of super
energy you can regain once your super
ends at 50 percent
skull of dire amenkara increase the
amount of super refunded per kill but
total super gain is capped at 50 percent
phoenix protocol sensing a trend yes cap
the amount of super energy you can
regain once your super ends at 50
percent storm transit breaks this one's
a little different now also refunds up
to 50 of your super energy
after your super ends based on the
number of kills that never did that
before that all that was was just
granted energy before and that needs to
happen though because yeah exotic was
useless useless completely
geomax
where's teddy
where's teddy
geo remove sprint to top off your super
this part of the perk led to a higher
uptime in pvp than was healthy and gave
a two men of control warlocks and
immediate renewable supply of super
energy for paying for mod costs like
special finisher and pve
overall thoughts briefly on the super
reworks fair yay day where yeah trav
yeah i think geo mags definitely needed
to happen some of the other ones i
actually don't think the 50 cap is
really going to change much because for
example when you're doing the erso
furiosa strat in grand masters really
that strat isn't about your refund it's
about the fact that you're generating a
ton of orbs and putting them on the
ground and then helping your guys like
give each other your super and that's
still going to be happening and the fact
that it's capped at 50 really doesn't
change that it just means that you're
going to have a few fewer orbs
accumulating every time you use it but
the strata is still going to be the same
it's like pull up the wall
take as much damage as you can drop all
those orbs like mad and then let your
friend pick them up like yeah djs does
we we did that a couple of try to get it
i mean that's the way to do it that's
like that's the meta for uh grand
masters which i don't think that's gonna
change it but it will change some of the
other like cheesy stuff that isn't that
is a little bit less cooperative and
geomag's like in particular like thank
god that's that's happening because yeah
yeah yeah that's uh one for gl max it
was it was a good run
but we know it was good wrong man it was
something
sorry teddy but scream overall like dude
what's your do you agree with the
philosophy on this do you think this is
a heavy-handed bungee approach is daddy
being unfair
i'm kind of of the opinion it's not
really going to change much either
i mean
yeah some of this stuff it sounds it
sounds like a lot but is it really
you know like is it really like you said
like the orbs
i mean have you seen how many orbs that
can drop
it's ridiculous it's like 20 yeah yeah i
can get
uh you can get like two supers out of
one so
you know
we'll see i think though yeah the geo
mags uh i haven't really used them that
much but
it's not beastie
those are the ones for um middle tree
middle tree yeah because basically you'd
get to about 80
and all you have to do is sprint and
you'll see the indicator on the screen
say topping off uh chaos reach and then
it'll really push you right to that 100
in seconds and yeah
yeah i was actually using those a bit um
it's actually sin told me to use them uh
for the uh
um grand master getting last way to take
out the champions but um
yeah we'll see i mean like i said i
don't think it's gonna it's gonna change
much none of the ones that they
mentioned are really the my go-to
exotics so
you know
fair enough
i'll jump in right quick i'm sorry
no no that's what you can do
you're good i'm good yeah okay no no
he'd be a messy with geo mag he's right
though he's right man he's right you
play trials or comp that's literally
what happens it's just warlocks running
into the walls or circles and it's just
like all right dude like is this that's
the only way you're going to beat me
really is that you have a beam that's an
instant kill and then the fact that they
now nerfed the beam going through walls
so geomag warlocks you know look you had
a run it was it was fun look actually
the thing i got out of this the most to
be with storm dresses storm dancers
brace because that was the one that made
um
the storm caller actually more powerful
with each kill if i remember so
that is exciting to me that it's going
to also refund a little bit of super
energy that's going to get a lot of play
now and with the perks to the uh buffs
to storm caller i believe last week
stone court look out for that that
exactly that's gonna that's gonna be
pretty that could be in the meta so look
out for that one let's get right into
these retunes and reworks hunter
bombadiers
all right so now the bomb now has a
secondary fact based on your subclass
type it blinds for arc blinds for solar
slow for stasis suppressors or solar
sorry burn for solar correct slow for
stasis suppress for void note the
suppression will not add a guardian in
super effect a guardian super excuse me
graviton forfeit increases the bonus of
invisibility duration the melee
regeneration speed now increases based
on the number of enemies near you while
you are invisible your recovery is
greatly increased and your weapon
reloads more quickly lucky pants added
intrinsic hand cannon holster mod
replace previous functionality with the
following when you ready a fully loaded
hand cannon that deals kinetic damage or
damage matching your subclass energy
type for a short time each hit against
the combatant from that hand cannon
increases the damage of the next shot
note no hawkmoon won't be able to
one-shot a raid boss using these legs
other hand cannons will get a fun edge
in combat though
what is a hand cannon holster mod a new
kind of mod that reloads stowed weapons
more on that below really quick on the
hunters how we feeling
bombardiers graviton bombardier seems
like the most uh interesting change uh
i'm sure it will annoy me to no end to
crucible but i i like i like what it's
going for the fact that it has
different ways it can be used based on
the the subclass you have equipped so
that's kind of interesting anything else
got your your fancy forfeit pants
bombardier screen
you muted sir muted
you're muted sir
yeah you probably muted in um
there you go sorry there you go
uh i feel like graviton forfeit is going
to be something i i have an issue with
i don't i mean i just feel like i don't
play hunter a lot in the crucible
but they annoy me already so
an invisible one just
more invisible more health that just
seems like it's going to annoy me
you might see that uptick in pvp that's
what you as you're concerned about it
was always the coolest looking exotic i
will say definitely one of the coolest
yeah it was one that i like to use it
was actually the first one i ever got um
whatever the season was that that came
out on my hunter and i remember like
using it quite a bit back in d1
it'll
be interesting but
fair enough look pretty much agree with
you guys um all i gotta say is
this hand cannon holster mod we learned
about that that's interesting so curious
to see what that is but largely i just
got to see how it plays out that's how i
feel about the hunters titan
precious scars will now have will now
also create a burst of healing and bonus
recovery around you whenever you kill an
enemy with a weapon
why is travis making that whose damage
type matches your subclass type ice fall
mantle remove the slower class ability
recharge scaler titans where you're at
this this whole section confuses me
there's like a lot of titan exotics that
are useless and the fact that they chose
these ones
is mind-boggling to me first of all
precious scars like i maybe i'm wrong
maybe that'll be super cool but it just
seems to me like a very specific use
case like oh if you kill an enemy on a
thursday using a sidearm in your
secondary slot then in those
circumstances you'll get this like buff
and it's just like all right well that
that's never going to happen
so i got to be a thursday
i don't know i'm just saying like i love
that i love it it says it says whenever
you kill an enemy with a weapon whose
damage type matches your subclass type
like you have to think
that's too much that's so much one
benefit yeah you're right
why yeah so i just don't want to
yeah and then icefall mantle like yeah
that that's a good way to buff it but
that that was such an underwhelming
exotic you're gonna have to do a lot
more to get people to use it in my
opinion and meanwhile there's like 15
titan armor exotics that are useless
useless
triple f tier trash and and we
yeah
and this is like this is what we're
we're we're buffing uh
these exotics that i forgot were in the
game
like okay cool
get them trapped get them i don't i
don't get this one the hunter and the
warlock ones made sense to me with the
titan section i was like all right so
you're doing nothing for titanic got it
message received thank zavala yes
zavala wasn't standing up for us at that
uh
he wasn't in the sandbox meeting yeah
i put these into the all right exotics
meaning when i get them i go all right
and then i move on um so
i think
i think i sort of agree that like
you know the thing about this precious
star thing though is that's so specific
that there's going to be something that
that's going to be like essential for
like i don't know what but it's going to
be you know you'll be trying everything
you can possibly think of to get this
one activity done and then somebody is
going to be like have you you haven't
you're not using precious scars man like
what's wrong with you
and you're going to be like i didn't
even i
not only did i forget that was in uh in
the game but like who came up with that
name
fair enough look you guys said it best
there's nothing more i could add to this
i do feel for you titan delegation i do
feel you guys got the short end of the
stick on exotic reworks very surprised
very surprised that they've not been a
lot of love your way so i do sympathize
but we got more likes to talk about the
better class let's get to it verity's
bro
changes to trig change to trigger when
you get a weapon kill that matches your
subclass energy type here we go again
increased grenade damage bonus to 20 per
stack but they got another buff on top
of that true eric that's the difference
true you're absolutely right you're
absolutely right the stag which i do use
grants damage reduction to allied
guardians standing in your rifts
interesting 25 percent against
combatants 15 against players i'm
reading this raw off the flight and then
promethean spur holy this useless thing
is going to get something oh i got to
read this out a lot i got a lot has
additional functionality while standing
in a riff solar weapon kills give you
class ability energy
when your class ability energy is full
solar weapon kills consume that energy
and spawn a combination healing
empowering rift at the target's location
bro
scream we busted out the spurs
yeah i still don't think people will use
that but that is a cool little person
it's interesting so basically could be
good in pve solar weapon kills consume
that energy and spawn a combination at
the target's location i'm thinking about
like maybe like in a rave could it could
be yours like i don't know i gotta look
at it keep your eye in it keep your eyes
open for other changes that come in the
wake of these as well our goal for the
next few seasons especially following
the launch of the witchcreen is to
increase the variety of fun and powerful
choices available to players in pve and
pvp alike let's go to the warlock
delegation screen real quickly verdi's
browse stack promethean spur
prometheus does that when they say
target location does that mean
whatever you just killed this location
or your location
that's what i'm trying to reach what is
that i mean am i reading that corr
incorrectly am i saying yes solar weapon
kills consume the energy and spawn a
combination healing power
so i'm gonna say at the target's
location meaning what you've killed
because the way the the way
the exotic worked before which was
completely useless which was you had
your super in dawn blade right right you
killed an enemy and then where you
killed the enemy
the rift became that's where the rift
was so i didn't find any practical use
for that and then you had to wait to get
your super to get it so now it seems
with this class ability energy and now
just regularly using it without the
super
needed they added this wherever you kill
someone a rift is going to be kind of
right so it's like a leapfrog type of
thing yes it also does it also does
healing and empowerment
that's cool that's cool yeah running
running around with a solar shotgun
killing things and then standing in the
rift and
that makes it like a little mini well of
radiance almost yeah yeah almost like
mini wells based on where the enemies
are killed
so i mean if you i could see like uh you
know if you could um i could see doing
something like if you had some sort of
massive damage over time weapon and you
just let all the enemies like maybe even
a sword or something that can do a lot
of damage to everything that's around
you you could just like
kill a whole bunch of enemies and then
essentially be in a well of radiance
because like everything around you will
essentially be a wealth well it uses it
uses your class ability right but i mean
like um yeah so you would have to
yeah it uses your energy so when it's
full it consumes that energy and spawns
a combination riff so i think the way it
would need to work is you kill something
with a soul or let's say you're running
around with a shotgun so you can get in
close to range of solar shotgun right
and kill something you're already
standing on its location it spawns a
rift and then you switch to another
solar weapon maybe your heavy weapon
slot and you just kill stuff and that
charges your your uh class ability again
and then you you know you just like
rinse and rep repeat
this cycle right yeah you kind of would
have to do your entire build around it
which is why i don't think it's going to
be very dominant i think maybe maybe you
have one guy who likes to use this and
it works for them but i just don't see
it becoming the meta yeah
fair enough stag anything else you good
warlock delegation there um
yeah i think grandstand damage reduction
in allied standing in your rift 25
that's i think that's a good
a good buff to the stag okay uh yeah i
mean all it was before was just yourself
and you got hurt right whatever so well
it gives a little thing to the well i
guess whatever you know interesting in
trials because it says 15 against
players players yeah yeah so that would
be interesting in trials but you know
the only thing about that exotic is it
one half of it kicks off when you're
dead
right
so yeah you know it is what it is if
you're the guy that keeps messing up you
know you keep getting picked in trials
to this this exotic for you will help
your friend i guess but anyway so there
we got that so look
finders scavengers and holsters oh my
all this is new to me and reading this
off the fly we are rolling out some
changes to mods that affect the
animal economy running double ammo
scavenger mods makes it too easy to have
100 uptime with special weapons in both
pvp and pve and pvp specifically we
believe that this is an important factor
in how oppressive certain special
weapons feel reducing their
effectiveness is a step towards
addressing this we are prepared to
revisit this depending on how it plays
when it's out in the wild we're also
looking to improve ammo finder to make
it easier to earn special and heavy ammo
and pve while introducing a new type of
leg armor mod that reloads stowed
weapons so now ammo finder now has an
increased chance to spawn ammo on kills
with primary weapons and further
increased chance with exotic primaries
scavenger multiple copies of scavenger
mobs of the same type no longer stack
wow
holster this is a new type of leg armor
mod that will gradually reload stowed
weapons of the matching type over time
multiple copies of holster mods of the
same type will increase the rate ammo is
reloaded the following weapon types will
have hosted mods auto rifle fusion
grenade launcher power it's all of them
all of them pretty much yeah i'm like
okay thank you for saving me for that
that's like all of them i think it's all
except rocket launcher except rocket
launch thank you uh hand cannon excludes
ariana's vow oh so yeah that makes sense
it makes sense really that would be
really okay yeah rocket launches breach
loaded grenade launches and bulls will
not have holster mods as we don't want
to affect any weapon that has a magazine
size of one
ammo finder trav where are we at with
this how we feeling
yeah it seems like scavenger had to die
so that holster could live right like
they're kind of they're kind of nerfing
what scavenger does so that you have to
get this other mod to reload your
weapons while they're stowed but we'll
see how how that works i'm i'm glad that
ammo finder is going to be
buffed a little i just have always
thought it's not a good mechanic that i
have to think about my ammo and like
manage that economy while i'm playing a
shooter i just
that really bothers me sometimes over
like the reason i can't beat an
encounter is because i don't have enough
ammo uh you know and back in the day i
used to pop on ammo since which was a
terrible idea but at least there was a
solution now it's like if you just get
if you get bad with that rng you just
kind of have to sit around and wait for
your ammo to come back which i've i've
done in grand masters and stuff so
um
yeah i mean they seem like i'm always a
fan of them giving more uh mods it seems
like in this case they're giving a mod
to
weaken another mod but still provide a
way for you to reload weapons but
whatever i'm i'll i'm sure it'll be fine
and it gives you more mods so that's
cool no doubt scream where you at man um
scavenger are you a double are you a
dirty double scavenger
user
it depends on what i was using but i
kind of agree with travis it just seems
like a mod rework um they don't want you
to double
they want you to have two mods so that
it seems
i don't know
more like in smart just
yeah a little bit yeah but
i don't think it's really going to
change
that much i agree that like
i kind of feel like they should bring
back
uh
ammo synth in a way
but i got because i kind of like them i
wish there was like a way you could
trade something for something else so if
you had like an overabundance of one say
you had an overabundance of special ammo
you could like trade up for primary or
for heavy if you wanted to but
um
yeah these sort of things i mean you
always throw them on you never i never
really find myself thinking that much
about it you know just kind of
uh
i guess trying to trying to find as much
it's always like this the last thing
like if i'm putting up a build putting a
build together it's always like okay and
i'll put
uh an ammo scavenger mod on this because
it works here i have room for it you
know right
no i mean i hear yeah this was
definitely surprising to read obviously
this is new to me um
i think for me the interesting one is
the um
what is it the the the holster the
gradual so basically i shot the new red
in the chat it's almost
the reconstruction perk in a mod
because when we had reconstruction of
deep stone and you'd have those weapons
you know automatically reload and stuff
so that's interesting that they're
encouraging that play style right
reconstruction happens when you're using
the weapon though that is true you're
right not when it's sold you're
absolutely right yeah but was it what
is there a per i feel like there's
something in the game that when it's
stowed maybe i'm loading yeah there's um
i think there's a titan exotic that does
that exact thing it like reloads your
your uh auto rifles or something yeah
yeah so there's a few exotics that have
like this intrinsic perk that i'm sure
will need to get reworked now
of course they didn't put anything about
them in the
12 with the armory but you know
but yeah i mean look at the auto loading
holster yeah but that that yeah true and
it's interesting that they're
encouraging that play style which to me
encourages swapping weapons
but you know they're definitely against
scavenger
with having a lot of the ammo so it's an
interesting gameplay choice remains to
be seen how much this affects and i just
thought the um what is it ammo you can
you have a chance to spawn ammo with the
primary weapons okay fine whatever the
next one oh yeah shout out to new rap
peacekeepers salute yup
the next one here we go oh warm mine
cells they just straight up
i'm coming to you for this one what to
be blunt these are currently too
powerful daddy has decreed
this is getting the nerf y'all it's
coming down this isn't a surprise even
at the introduction we knew they were
very strong that was the point at the
time they were created they were only
expected to last for about a year at
least they're honest so we could push
the envelope on something cool and
flavorful knowing that they wouldn't be
around breaking things forever within
the force of rasputin's explosive wrath
they would have a time to shot but
eventually leave and make room for the
next exciting thing okay so they go
they're going on bloating let's get to
it
base warming cells
reduced radius of the explosion effect
range of the wall myself from 10 to 6
meters
reduced damage of the explosion of war
mine sales previously 200 to 400 now 50
to 250
global reach increased the mod cost of
global reach to three
reduce the amount of radius increase 20
to 10
cellular suppression reduce the duration
of the suppressing effect when using
cellular suppression three seconds to
two
no not red the rescue it reduced bonus
solar damage previously 100 to 200 now
25 to 100
damn
i gotta go straight to scream this is
you bro this is
whoa
you you're my guy we do these grand
masters you got the builds bro sad they
pull it out
although they don't say anything about
the um the healing ones which are
also kind of important like i actually
end up using a lot of those
so
you know
we'll see i mean
it's gonna be
i mean i think every good build you have
to have at least something that creates
a warming cell like if i don't know
endgame activity has been like undoable
without having something uh that creates
a warming cell for me since
which season did they come out in was it
um
season of the
chosen season i can't even remember
they'd be like no it was the um no it
was way before that uh yeah it was way
before it was like last it was during
the fall
yeah it's been a minute y'all chat to
help us out what's seasonal
yeah when did war myself debut i can't
remember but yeah it's been a while
season was that it was when we had those
uh like um public events
where you'd
yeah you have the towers show up and
where are they are the rivals
says worthy
she's enough worthy that seriously did
last mad long i remember that scene i
think or was that arrival
yeah i mean my joint the bunker season
outside the bunker season yeah
but um
yeah i mean
i think that this had to happen
eventually because i mean if you see
anybody like speedrunning anything
they're using um
rather rasputin you know they're using
global reach so
i just hope that
it's it's they've been probably the most
dynamic mods that i've seen in the game
um i hope they were
i hope that it means that there's
something else that's kind of coming i
like the next section we're going to get
into that but get continue
um yeah so
i guess we'll as we read we'll we'll see
how they're they're going through it i
think it will be one of those things now
where um
yeah the damage reduction is
they're they're i just hope they don't
become completely useless right that's
the thing with bungie sometimes yeah
yeah right i don't want them to be just
some super purpose thing you know
bro this hurts it hurts me to hear you
have to read this like i know how much
you love this build like this you know
it's trav when i run knight falls this
man like this is part of his dna
yeah to see him clear rooms with
effectiveness and efficiency
you know so i felt this one i was like
damn i didn't that that would hit hard
for my boy so
pour one outfit on but but to you trav
like where are you at with this is this
you gonna go cry the car
but y'all like dude
is it are we overreacting do you think
it was time
like trav where are you at with this
yeah i say burn it down i'm glad this is
happening honestly i would be okay if
they took it out of the game altogether
um
this is one of the more annoying things
about uh the sandbox right now in my
opinion is that there's like people who
play the end game pve activities you
don't even know how to play the game
without war and i think it's just yeah i
just think it's like a crutch honestly
like they're they're it's it's such a
it's such a important part of people's
build and guess what in order to
generate we're not warming cells you
have to use a very specific set of
weapons that have been in game forever
and it makes the pve sandbox uh less
interesting and
i i just my experience with with playing
with warming cells is that there's
always one really irritating guy in the
group who insists that everybody have
war minds
and is always like hey you're you're
getting in the way of my war mine cells
and like you got that guy
they're just
yeah dude especially when i do lfg
there's always one guy who's just super
irritating and everything's about his
warming cells like i get out of my way i
got my water mine cells oh i dropped a
warm cell guys to get i'm gonna shoot
the warm cell now so everybody it's just
like just burn it down just burn it down
we don't need this in the sandbox there
are other ways to play end game
activities and like it's a crutch i
think i think just get rid of it man
it's been it's been there for a long
time nobody can say it didn't get its
time in the sun it did now it's time to
kill it and think thank
[Laughter]
i think it will be better for the
sandbox i think it'll be better for all
of us it's it's one of those things just
pull off the band-aid you'll live and uh
we'll uh we'll we'll figure it out
look oh this is interesting i i i knew
it was coming and my my gut told me it
was coming especially
when
um
they unset sun setting right so
i i said okay they have a lot of these
powerful things running around and yes
it it's had its run i was surprised it
was as heavy-handed as it was to be
honest but um
you know
to transport yes it's been it's been
around but it is funny to hear you
complain about these people who love
this build but whatever you know it is
what it is you don't like that guy but
um yeah i mean you know to me it look
was it inevitable probably gonna happen
at some point yes the question now is
see well this is where i'm gonna scream
you're gonna make other things fun
but is this going to completely
kill this thing now
that that that's what i'm concerned like
is it like i mean it's additive though
how can you kill it it doesn't it
doesn't take away those weapons or make
them worse it's something that the
weapons do on top of the stuff they
already do so making that a little bit
less
it's not like you're you're going to see
a war mine sell and go oh well that's
not even worth shooting it you know what
i mean like
an additional thing i think what i guess
my way i should have said better is that
basically the way destiny players
operate in my opinion is optimum
efficiency right so whatever is the
utmost thing from a statistical level
the destiny player will gravitate
towards that and let's just say now is
we're going to get into this next
segment which is elemental wells i'm
very curious to see what they're going
to say about that because again i
haven't read it and this is all me live
reading um you know just to see if that
now becomes a new thing and as a result
but to your point yes it is additive you
are absolutely right it is it is an
additive thing it's not complete being
completely taken away but have some
sympathy for the for those that that
lost this this baby man it's so cold
such a cold-hearted person
i don't need his sympathy
moving
good i mean it's a good thing you don't
need it because you will never get it
nothing
but we go move on because uh looks like
they got something hopefully in this
place elemental wells two elemental well
mods two
are getting improvements in order to
make them a more competitive choice when
compared to the other combat style mods
elemental ornaments now have an
increased chance to spawn an elemental
well based on the tier of the enemy
defeated font of might don't even know
what this is base duration has been
increased to 10 seconds and increased
the damage bonus provided from 10 to 25
percent and there you have it with
abilities and armor down we have one
sandbox type left to cover weapons we'll
see you again next week for our next
final season 15 flight check so trev i
got to ask like um
do you use elemental well bills don't
you even i haven't really messed with
them so i just want to know if any yeah
i mean i i used them during the season
when they came out however long ago that
was but um
yeah i they they were not super good at
the time and i don't think they ever
have been so it's nice that they're
giving them some buffs i think if they
can put these little mini mechanics in
the games like wells and war mine cells
and make them just give a little bit of
boost for people that want to play that
way i think that's great i just don't
think anyone should define how you play
the game or be have like a massive
influence on the sandbox or that sort of
thing and so
i think wells will probably still have a
little bit to go before they before you
start seeing people using them but i
would like there to be a lot of these
little
little mini mechanics that you can do
into your build that give you a little
bit of an edge but i just think that
they shouldn't i shouldn't have to log
on one season and be like well this is
mandatory yeah or like people are going
to be on my case or like this is the
only way to play the game so i have to
be using this set of weapons
i just never really liked that man maybe
it's just because i'm resistant to
authority but like
somebody if somebody tells me like oh
you have to use it yeah yeah you like me
i'm just like
watch me not exactly i won't explicitly
yeah so hold up hold up we gotta stop
the show i gotta interrupt you for a
second the legend the cheetah is in the
chat coming from barbados
have a great show we miss you i got i
got i got the you in the back there you
know i'm saying a ninja in the cheetah
over there you know chilling but yo
salute bro yeah enjoy your vacation we
miss you safe travels on the way back
next week you're right in time for the
big one you know what i'm saying so it's
good enjoy man we gonna hold it down for
you till you come back he says thanks
all coming back tomorrow okay cool but
it should be a full show another tease
of set bonus with iron banner oh how
they play with my heart yeah yeah yeah
no doubt no doubt good to see e i'm
gonna check the cheetah no doubt but um
yeah let me ask you uh
scream like wells do you even use these
do you have you
tinkered
does ark buddies count as a well is that
kind as a no that's something else
entirely i don't think i have i mean
i i have to say i mean i am
i'm a war mind cell guy but it wasn't
because i always thought that that was
like the best thing it just i actually
just really liked it it was like one of
the fun things where yeah i was like
this is a really
cool thing like there was times where
people would i would be playing like
endgame activity and i wouldn't have any
mods equipped whatsoever i would just
have like
because i you know i i feel like if you
played a lot of d1 like there was just
i don't know like your mindset was just
different sometimes and like i i the
whole mod thing i didn't really
like get into as far as pve activity uh
at first i used a lot like like i would
use like targeting like mods for pvp
like the sniper rifle mods and stuff
like that but i just never really found
like any of them did that much so i
would just forget and then like the war
mine thing came out and i
was like oh okay these actually do
something
like interesting and you know i like
seeing the ball pop out
about that just i was like your face
jeff fix your face
yeah so you know i didn't really use it
that much um but maybe i will now can
you give me an example of one like maybe
i have used one i'm just like basically
for what i recall you read the the con
the the flavor text it's like you do
some activity and then a well will drop
and then i believe that yeah
it gives you a buff some of them would
give you um the ability to recharge you
know very fast on your lowest ability
okay okay yeah i think i did
i didn't mess with you i'll use them
more yeah
they really doubled down on new ones
with season of the spicer with the with
the uh server that there was a new track
there i think i saw a couple but i just
didn't commit because in fairness to
travis
my over reliance on either wore my cell
bills and to be honest i'm not even
either i'm where they gonna get me which
they haven't seen in just yet is the
charge with light i'm gonna charge with
light guy like that's i'm all i'm a
charger yeah like i that i i will be
affected if they like because i'm all
about this supercharge getting you know
picking up the um the what is it when
you pick up the orb and then you're
already in a charger like times two
status and the protective light
protective light charged with light is
in a really good place for this mechanic
though because it feels like a little
mini mechanic that some people use and
they get minor bonuses but it's not
mandatory and it doesn't control
your loadout and and the sandbox so i
just think they need to get warming
cells and wells uh to that like state
and then add on to it and then just keep
going and give their make it make their
be a wider variety of different little
mini games you could do and ways you can
kind of
work your load out i think that'll be
awesome
but yeah no i agree i agree so
interesting changes let's get into the
next part of this top fit for an iron
lord so last season they said sally's
brought some fresh weapons okay okay we
got the
forges pledge pulse rifle and the peace
bond sidearm each available through the
packages bounties match awards and
seasonal iron banners quest but that's
not all it's been some time since oh oh
we got a new set some fresh armor to
earn pull from the depths of forgotten
caesar they know they ain't been making
no content these pieces worn by warriors
of the past are ready to battle once
more including the iron four runner set
okay so starting next season we'll be
introducing the iron lord's pride
intrinsic perk through this set a set
perk
wearing a piece of this armor grants a
small chance of an enhancement prism
dropping at the end of an iron banner
match each additional piece screams
laughing each additional feed roller
design each additional piece worn
increases the chance capping out at four
pieces total y'all you you're not
bubbling with this excitement defeating
your foes with the fury of the iron
forge show no mercy in a few weeks you
can relate to like all your rewards trav
take it away let's go yeah so
uh first of all thanks bunji i hate it
uh
the like so i like the
i'm really glad that they're doing set
perks i think everybody who's played
destiny is like look this isn't every
other game like it's a good mechanic it
should exist um it also gives um it also
gives armor use now that we have uh
transmog it's it gives a way for for
your armor set to actually matter so i'm
glad that we've got set bonuses
this perk is
bad and nobody's gonna nobody's gonna
use it for that because nobody needs
enhancement prisms i mean there are some
people who need it but
it just it's not a high priority it's
not going to get me to wear the armor
third of all your armor looks ugly i'm
sorry all three sets
look pretty pretty gross to be honest
actually for once the titans have the
coolest looking set but coolest is a
really
really overselling it because all these
look like
uh
like they they ran through a wardrobe
and came out on the other side with
whatever clutched onto their body like
in a cartoon uh but yeah uh i'm glad
that perks are happening i'm glad we
have armor i will not complain or i just
did complain i will uh i will do my best
to not complain because we're getting
new armor which like that alone is
something we've been missing for seasons
the fact that you put a perk bonus on it
as well is even better um but yeah the
per bonus is not exciting that itself
doesn't look great before i pass it to
scream do you think um by the way you're
not showing your iron lord's pride right
now i'm very disappointed you're not not
prideful right now with what they're
doing
but but
my question to you chad is do you think
because from our understanding it's not
a mod right so do you think this is
going to behave almost similar to how
remember gambit prime sets used to work
and just the equipment like do you think
we at least you're happy that it's going
in that direction yes that bonus so
maybe that could work something for the
future i'm i really think that this is
them like
giving us a wink that like they're going
to do set bonuses and see in the the
witch queen because that's something
that like
i think they know that they're missing
and and something that would like
bungie very rarely misses out on
opportunities to create things that make
us want to be more addicted and more
collect-y about about destiny and this
is one area that they're missing it a
lot because there's not really a reason
to collect the armor
and this could give us a a really big
reason to want to do it so
um i i think this is them giving us a
little nod and a wink to their plans for
the future um
this exact one in terms of what the
armor looks like in the perk it does
isn't great and if that's the future if
the future is every armor set just gives
you a better shot at a a
currency a currency in destiny i'm gonna
be very upset but uh you know i'm not
gonna complain it's a new set of armor
man that's more than we've gotten in
past seasons it's a it's got a uh
intrinsic perk that gives an armor bonus
set i'm not gonna complain about that so
um it's good and it's bad i ju i just uh
it makes me excited for the future not
excited to get this set of armor
fair enough lord scream um my iron lord
banner lord we always running
deep in banner so we i'm expecting the
full set right pride we're going to get
these prisons we're going to do this
what are we doing
i think tokens are getting pulled over
still yeah till next season yeah i got
six thousand so
i'm getting that done
uh
yeah i got really excited there and then
subsequently got really sad
i totally agree like armor
armor bonuses oh god like it seems like
such a missed opportunity and for so
long like i'm like why haven't
like of all the things that like
like i never want to allude to like talk
about another game really but like
like the one thing that always made me
want to play world of warcraft when i
was in college was the fact that i had
to go and do like this and that and over
there to try to get my
armor like so that i could get the
bonuses from having the full set and
uh yeah i i isaac somebody who never
really
goes after a specific p like any sort of
set of armor at all like if i get a
piece and it's a good role it's like
okay great and now with transmog it's
like okay i can make it look however i
want you know but uh i would i've always
wanted that like i've always wanted like
a reason to have a specific set um
yeah but that's like
it better not be
for for materials or if it is it should
be for some like serious material like
you know like an ascendant no don't
compromise no materials we're not doing
this for currency this isn't a day job
okay like i
the other thing is i will say this that
is good i'm glad they limited it to four
armor pieces because i would hate it if
there was a possibility of five and then
you have to choose to not use things so
i'll say that like they that's already
like they're thinking ahead that that
makes me happy yeah so i hope it's for
something you know like it'd be great to
get like
you know a boost to a weapons type or
um
you know i like it
you know they have
you obviously you get a lot when you
master work a piece of armor so it would
it would almost like you'd need to get
like like even if you got like a like an
extra mod place or something like that
when you had all of them that would be
kind of cool um yeah no i think i'm
sorry i agree i mean travis you knocked
out the paw brother it's like
it's like they they have the opportunity
to teasing
and they need like it's a missed
opportunity with a currency don't don't
don't tie it to a currency of all
currencies yeah and of all currencies
that on top of it it's redundant because
if you remember i'm the guy that i
configure my ghost to already do that so
when i play different activities i'm
switching and putting my crucible one on
to get the up upgrade module or if i win
or the enhancement prism with the with
the headshot is that going stack you
know what i'm saying but at the end of
the day it should not be tied to
currency the thing if any division guys
or anything that i'm always jealous of
division and outriders are set
bonuses and i understand they may be
nervous and with putting it dipping
their toe as far as balancing but you're
already they're already doing it with
stuff like you know the wells and the
charged with light on some level because
like was it powerful friends there's
ones that give you plus 10 strength and
you know there's stuff that even even on
stasis like if you look at those stasis
shards and stuff and all that like
they're giving you intellect buffs and
all that let us have these set bonuses
and let us play
and what's also cool is since they don't
like us having to over as an over
alliance they don't like to overrealize
on exotics this would force legendary
play if you give us those stat bonuses
right and not be use those as a crutch
so
it just bothers me you know that that
they they
i don't know if they technically can't
do it right now based on how they're set
up but they got to know
like this is what people want so yeah i
would i would like that and then the
last point shout out to the irl titan he
just left
but look
i'm not one to criticize
artists and you know i i don't know how
to make the any of this right
but i must admit since d2
there's been a problem i have with the
artistic
of the iron banner sets
we all know those d1
sets are a gold mine that they're
sitting on right now
the furnace chests remember the
the wool collars the you know the the
fell winter's peak line give can we get
the fell which is p calvin klein set
could i get that i'm waiting for that
like that it's like i would literally
throw money at tests all day even if
they monetized it i'm sure that's what
they'll do i'm sure you'll you'll have a
synth weave you can buy uh you know in a
couple in a couple seasons
yeah but i just missed that man like i
want that over-the-top iron lord stuff
like fit into it you know this the
warlock delegation we ain't really doing
good but anyway um side note before we
get back on focus um weapons how are you
guys feeling we got this pulse we got uh
what do you think this is and you know
this p spawn sidearm are we at least
excited for new weapons
yeah
yeah watch out that sandbox sounds good
i always like the uh the pulse rifle
meta so
you know hopefully they come yeah i
don't know if it's coming back but well
right now messenger's out here bro yeah
i mean
um i would like
i did like pulse rifles so yeah
[Music]
no doubt so pretty much it looks like
some light stuff we got the prime
rewards
fireworks i'm not gonna get too deep
into that they're supporting sand
castles i don't see anything else
in there pretty much up pretty much it
yep looks like that's it they got the
movie the week and all that good stuff
so overall
boys we have made it to the end you know
just want to get our closest thoughts
before um
two things one
over all these changes as a whole you
know obviously we had set some sandbox
then
we got this we got ability tunings
what's going on timmy salute you know
exotic armor tuning now they're saying
next week
weapons
right and then after that
we we roll in into into witch queen so i
mean the release the reveal supposedly
on the 24th so how we feeling with the
structure overall with these changes let
me get screen let's get the guest screen
like
leading into the to the which cream
review are you happy with this direction
or are you uh you know how are you
feeling overall about all this
combination of changes
um you know i think it's
typical if that makes sense you know i
mean i think there's always kind of
these things i i don't think it's
drastic
there's always
changes like this that happen towards
the end of the season
it's i think it's you know
there was a time
certainly a long time ago where we
thought all right well the game just
need we just need to change this one
thing and then the game's perfect you
know oh we need to you know we need to
change this one thing and the game is
perfect you know and i think destiny is
just evolved into it's the game of
change you know you do something for a
while you give it its moment and then
you you move on to the next thing that's
part of it i think it's part of what
keeps it fun part of what keeps it new
and interesting i think at this point uh
there's there's no perfect
um perfect moment for the game
so
um yeah i don't think the changes are
drastic uh and
i'll just be interested to see
you know just really what kind of
how it plays out you know and what i end
up doing and what i end up using and
that kind of thing so do you have any
particular obviously we had the subclass
stuff before right this and now you have
a lot of armor and stuff like all you
already visualizing some things you
already like excited from from a build
and subclass and then obviously we
didn't get weapons yet but are you
formulating and are you in the lab
mentally about what you're gonna do to
combat
all this you know i'm not sure i mean i
might end up using
like an elemental well build that kind
of sounds maybe a little bit more
interesting again obviously war mines
won't be the thing that i kind of go to
so i'll have to to switch that out
as far as subclasses are concerned um
you know i mean i play warlock a lot
it's always the thing that i i i
looking strong from last week bro yeah
that could you know
detonate on it burst 75 percent more pve
there was and there was a way you used
to be able to like triple detonate your
nova warp i wonder if that'll be a thing
again yeah
i know about you
okay we know about your ex sport sir
yeah so we'll see you know uh that's
kind of always what depicts what i end
up doing is how well i can um exploit it
so
salute the scream always fighting away
yeah
something's affordable screen go and
find it but i feel you let's get traffic
man like where you at man like now week
two of some major changes we got one
more week of weapon changes and then the
reveal so how we feeling about this as
culminating into it the witch queen yeah
i guess i guess i'm still waiting for
weapons because
uh so far
i mean some of the changes are going to
affect me because
for example you know nova warp getting a
buff means i'm going to see that and uh
you know the the uh
warlock beam kamehameha
is finally getting yeah kind of like
finally getting its uh it's debuff and
it's come up it's
warming cells are
being essentially sunset i know we're
not supposed to use that word because
they say they don't sunset but they do
um
so there's stuff like that but in terms
of like playing as a titan none of these
none of these changes that have been
announced so far are really gonna affect
me i mean the the titan super changes
were pretty minimal compared to the
other ones and it's the same here with
the armor you know we got like a
footnote with two weapons that are two
armors that don't really get used so
it's mostly going to affect the sandbox
as a whole which is great but it's not
going to affect
my play style yet so i guess i'm just
waiting for weapons but so far so good i
mean they're getting their ducks in a
row in terms of like fixing the
outstanding issues that really need to
be fixed we got
you know stasis is sort of in the rear
view and has been for a while in terms
of it being dominant we have
these these outstanding exotics and
supers that maybe were a little bit
too weak or a little bit too powerful
and they're being brought in line and so
i see this as them you know they're
giving their house an order before they
and then they're giving themselves an
entire season to test out that that
house before they they launch a giant um
expansion against it so i think it's
stuff that needs to be done um i'm still
i'm still by far the most uh interested
to see what they do with weapons because
that's gonna actually affect how all of
us play um but yeah so far with the
supers and armor there haven't been a
lot of surprises and especially on the
titan the titan front i think like
yeah they really they really have the
titan delegation feeling titan
delegation is feeling utterly forgotten
about in armor and then super it's sort
of like i guess we'll see but so far
really the only thing that comes to mind
is like i guess we can throw that hammer
that all of us forgot or it was in the
game we can throw that a little bit more
now um so
we'll we'll see if they uh if they
actually affect anything but i am
excited to try out new subclasses
because i mean the arc subclasses were
so dominant for the better part of the
last year of destiny that um it's just
nice to see more variety and and see
some of these they're doing some
interesting stuff i still think
and what i was hoping that we'd see
during this whole sandbox review is
uh them changing the old light
subclasses to match the darkness
subclass in terms of how it worked with
mods and all that
i i still think they need to do that at
some point yeah they got deleted to it
but yeah
i still don't even think we're gonna get
that with witch queen to be honest i
think
yeah
i agree with you i agree i agree yeah so
yeah i just think i agree with myself uh
i uh i i think it's uh i just said i'm
agree or reflexively it's like it was me
who suggested it's like yeah i agree
with me man i'm super dope
[Applause]
[Laughter]
sorry i have to call myself out because
i know somebody else will
that was done
yeah uh so yeah i just i think it's i
think it's far off away but i still
think they need that because the future
of those subclasses is not
hopefully it's not going to depend on
bungie just deciding to buff and debuff
stuff hopefully it depends on them
actually expanding on them by putting
new mods and perks and modifiers that uh
let you kind of change that as that
subclass works
and until we have that i think it'll
always feel like
um
like they just didn't it doesn't really
have enough like focus on it
just because they put so much into
the stasis subclass yeah they did they
did um i think both you made fantastic
points i think it's for me i look at it
like
you know
they got stasis handled finally i felt
in pvp for the most part you know in a
good way where it's not oppressive
obnoxious you know that kind of thing so
i i think they wanted to get that out
the way you know we've got these major
changes i i admit you know obviously i'm
buying someone warlock so a lot of this
stuff does positively affect my class
but it it was it always always
of that mindset when i hate when things
are underused and they're not looked at
so i i got to get him credit like i
didn't think they would get prometheus
spurs stuff that i just look at i'm just
like rolling my eyes like who in the
hell is going to use this right and you
know what i'm saying like it's just like
come on you knew this out the gate
shouldn't it whatever but you know to
see that now to transport for the titan
delegation i am disappointed there
really wasn't a lot of tight and exotic
reworks i was expecting way more from
that so in that i do empathize with the
title like damn like there's mad exotics
i know they got that need love like
what's up like what's going on with that
so all right you know we see what's up
but um i like the sandbox stuff
i am curious and i want to flip this
back to you guys as well last final
question
with weapons right we know weapons is
next
so you know the vibe seems to be
less ability
you know
going back to the weapons you know what
do you guys want or you think they need
to do
to put weapons in a good place you know
so the start the shoe screen like what
do you need to see
for pvp or for pve or both both um
for pvp uh you know i've always been
well one i do think it's it's good that
they're going back to more of a weapons
thing because it is a first person
shooter and like in pvp i hate the fact
that like i can
hit every shot and lose a gun battle
because
well before stasis would nerf because
right several reasons yes yes correct
i was kind of disappointed that they
nerfed 120 hand cannons um because i
think 120s were actually like it should
always be risk versus reward maybe just
make him less regular don't make him a
sniper rifle make you know keep bringing
the range down a little bit okay they
were they were too strong they were
strong screaming you know
because they had range yeah
because you could like
hit like a truck right
from
like bring that down
that's fine okay we're there but i
always think that like
if it's
the lower the rpm the harder it should
hit yeah in the hands of a skilled
player
you know it should be like okay if
you're a skilled player and you want to
use 120s you're going to be really good
they're really difficult to use but
they're really strong you know so i
always feel like that's the way that
they should go with it
um hopefully they bring a little bit
more of that when it comes to
uh
pve yeah what you want um
yeah i mean a little bit more freedom
would be nice
uh you know again with the mods as
travis was talking about like i want to
be able to use the weapon that i want to
use
um you know within reason obviously i
mean if i'm going into uh you know a
grand master nightfall and the burn is
you know there's there's arc shields and
overload and unstoppable champions
obviously i have to use that but
um
you know i want to have
i don't know i mean i guess when you
talk about versatility it's like i want
to just be able to have like more than
one choice of the weapon you know what i
mean like
like
like let's say you're going into you
know you have a scout rifle it's like
there's always you'll only see people
using one or two scout rifles
why can't i use any scout rifle right um
but do you think that's more of an
efficiency thing or do you think that's
more to what you know travis is alluding
to
with the with the champion mods kind of
dictating play style so that people kind
of say well i'm gonna pick the best
effective one
of that class and then kind of run it
and everybody kind of follows suit well
yeah but i mean like as far as that
that doesn't always play into
like the rpms in pvp you know like the
archetypes in pvp you know it's like
people will use
like right now you can't use like what
is it 180 hand cannons right
again in in the crucible are like
fractions whatever yeah but in in pve
they're actually they're actually not
bad you will never find anybody using a
120 hand cannon in pve right and it's
like that's what you said well why you
know why not you know like they should
they should both be as effective in the
hands of the right player and to your
point i remember them alluding
that hand cannon specifically they were
like they realized they're
underperforming yeah npv so i do expect
that guaranteed next week they straight
up said they're going to address that
yeah that'll be in next week so
hopefully you know you you definitely
you definitely get that but i hear where
you're coming from and if you trap
quickly um you know where you at
obviously weapons you said it's very
important to you so what do you what do
you want to see from the pve side and
the pvp side
yeah so a couple things first they're
they're obviously going to do the thing
they always do and try to say look we
want all these weapons to have a role in
sandbox and we're going to try to make
them all equal and have a certain like
role and then they're they're not going
to make that they're not going to do it
successfully because people
find one outlier and they stick to it
and they figure out a way to min max and
all that stuff so i'm sure there will be
a
meta and it will favor one weapon type
or a couple weapon types over others and
that's just gonna happen
obviously i encourage them to continue
to try maybe one of these days they'll
get close but
so far it hasn't happened what i would
like to see is
a few things
we've got stasis energy types coming in
do something with that don't just make
it like another blank thing maybe
address the fact that we have three
energy types right now that just are
basically colors you know maybe do
something about that or at least tell us
your plans for that in the future of how
you're going to make these matter with
the fact that you now have four energy
types and
we can't go into an encounter with four
types of shields with only three weapons
if we're playing solo so there has to be
some sort of like fix there right unless
your your fix is that we all use the uh
the auto rifle that changes elements oh
yeah yeah
hardline shout out yeah
unless that's your unless that's your
solution to everything is that we use
that uh to game the system um
i also want them to just focus on perks
and mods i think that's more than
anything what the game needs right now
is just more of those so that and i i
would like them to hopefully not just
there's one god roll right if you if you
infuse the sandbox with a ton of mods
and perks and increase the weapon
variety i think it also increases the
odds that there's not one that just
becomes an outlier that everybody feels
compelled to use on all of their weapons
and i think that that would be that
would be great so
focus on mods and perks keep doing the
thing you do trying to balance and
failing and let's see if you can uh
do something about sniper rifles because
i feel like they get the short end of
the stick forever
that's just me yeah i just think sniper
rifles need to
they they are they're kind of like the
same thing what you were saying well
home where it's like high skill but it
pays off um and i feel like they're so
afraid of what the people with high
skill can do with sniper rifles that
they they tend to make them on the
weaker side so that even high skilled
people who can hit all their shots are
afraid to use one because it's so
situational and i don't think that's how
it should be with snipers so
interesting no i feel i feel you i think
it's um i'm very curious to see what
they do i personally want to use 180s
and pve i personally want to use i feel
like yeah outside like fake bringing has
to do something very special and firefly
and i got to throw a mod on it to make
the explosion better like i want to be
able to use legendary hand cannons you
know and other underperforming weapons
in pve i feel like i have to shoot red
bars way too many times just to get a
kill when you know you can go use a
pulse or something else and it's just
more effective so i'm curious with that
um yeah i think that i i it's like you
said there's always going to be
the bungee intent of what they want
every weapon to do and then it's going
to be the outliers that break that and
people are going to find it so it's to
me it's this never-ending they're not
really going to be able to balance this
game but i just
i'm curious to see what they think they
need to do to get things in a better
pocket in pve and pvp i'm
to be honest like outside of a
shatter dive hunter here and there that
kind of is annoying it's not too much i
mean y'all cash reach warlocks is wild
yeah we got to control them yeah yeah
they're out of control there's not too
much i'm upset while i'm just like
raging and i'm like all right this is bs
outside of cheating you know like that
i'm raging that that i'm always gonna be
on you know kind of thing so yeah you
know we'll see we see where it goes but
i'm excited i think uh i love all this
house cleaning right before
a big release so that's always exciting
and then we got to 24th you know i want
to see what they do it's going to be
pre-recorded is it going to be regular
because there's also gamescom that day
and i know you know what's going on you
know with hygienists so i'm curious to
know how bungie had please bungie
separate the time from the gamescom
thing because yeah that's going to be a
crazy day for me for streaming selfishly
so that's all i got but um yeah man one
in the they would just if they would
just do
different perks that can roll on weapons
that come from different sources and
help you with that game type that alone
would increase the amount of
variety you have in the sandbox because
you know getting a crucible weapon that
has a separate crucible perks versus a
pve weapon that's pv perks or even if
you went down to like
nightfalls versus raids and all that
stuff and that perks per like
you know specific activity right would
do a lot so i'm just hoping that they
they have fun with their sandbox a
little bit more but it's harder to do
with sunsetting gone it makes
experimentation much harder because then
you have to worry about
you know we can't wait for this weapon
to be gone we have to actively seek out
a solution and nerf it and that takes
additional resources rather than just
waiting the allotted 18 months for it to
go away so agree that's why my
prediction and he knows i said it
i think it's such sentence coming back i
i i i don't see how much longer it never
left nerfing is nothing is sunset you're
right nerfing is sun setting
but it it gets to a point like they
their whole argument was power creeping
so many weapons and so many weapons
they're still adding more weapons and
adding more weapons right so it's just
like i don't know it'll be not that i'm
calling for it i just don't see
you know
how it avoid it so
you know it is it is what it is but
we shall see we shall see but a lot of
exciting things coming up so let's close
this thing out of here salute the e for
pulling up you know what i'm saying in
the last minute what's going on let me
get a new rad right quick he said that's
how i started race speakers listen man i
know where you at with your osiris lore
stuff i get it new red i understand
where you're at all i'm saying there's
still enough evidence to suggest outside
of the leak
that that might not be osiris that's all
i'm trying to say so
just look at the lore card with the the
form the supposed sabothune thing i know
you're the lord of lord but i'm just
trying to say it's not out of the realm
of possibility that what you're what
people are saying that this could be
some truth to it that's all i'm trying
to say so anyway enough of that where
can the fine people find you let's get
with our guest
screen
the legendary youtuber
mobile legendary notorious maybe
[Laughter]
you can find me uh at youtube if you
type in wilhelm scream destiny you
should probably find me uh or on uh
twitter um and instagram you can find me
on that over
the one with the one
a little bit more confusing
thanks for having me guys this is a lot
of fun i really appreciate it
i'm impressed you guys kept star wars
talk to a minimum i was able to read it
live really just touched on it i should
have probably said it right now because
if i could go off another 10.
uh we'll save it for the party chat bro
exactly it was screamed love brother
glad you could make it always a pleasure
playing with shannon clan and always
look out for your content and yo man's
got good please subscribe wilhelm scream
really really cool you know i'm saying
content creative very chill and um yeah
my good friend of the realm and of
course the thai
the infamous thai the man with the
opinion the spicy takes the warmind cell
killer the no sympathy
no empathy for latch me
by that tiger travis what's going on is
there anything going on in your world
what could have been [ __ ] me standing
over lakshmi's corpse uh tapping
repeatedly
um
uh no you can find me on twitter at thai
guy travis uh you can read my articles
and reviews on ign.com i've got a review
uh for a game you've probably never
heard of coming out next week
which will be fun and uh yeah and then
you can you can see me here on uh this
podcast they seem to have me around for
the past couple uh weeks i think i think
they like me so you can probably find me
here uh and then i also have a new show
uh sunday mornings uh from 8 to 10 a.m
uh pacific which is called cast
bitcast where we talk about um just
general games industry stuff uh it's
something that's not in my portfolio yet
a show where i don't talk about destiny
exclusively yes um so yeah excited to be
a part of that uh and you can watch me
there on youtube no doubt man salute to
traps with everybody for pulling off i
know it's last minute but uh yeah we're
liking thursdays you know we're liking
thursday i ain't gonna lie traffic we're
gonna have to talk to eve
i'm kind of liking thursdays i'm just
saying i like having friday nights
what i'm saying so we go and then we're
live and right on direct with the you
know it's that fresh take so we'll speak
to e when he gets back i don't think
he's against it we just got to work out
the schedule and see what's going on but
yeah i do like it get that fresh take
raw reaction right as the 12 happens
this is pretty i like to stream it to
youtube
oh well i love the street
you know we gotta heal you too so it's
cool but again
cox just trying to change everything
this amazing dude on youtube or
thursdays now this is a show all this
stuff you've been helping me push my
brother along into to the light
i am i agree with all these changes so
yeah i've got no problem with it
especially having me on the show though
exactly exactly brilliant you're a smart
wise man you know that
my man salute the chat but again salute
everybody for pulling up new rad stitch
everybody man just having the jokes and
irl titan that's all lucas uh forte
everybody salute to supporting us and uh
yeah we'll be back hopefully next week
he will be back we have that uh week of
sandbox changes but that's all i got so
in typical last word fashion
this has been
the last last word we can't read nobody
ain't twitch but
sorry that's the thing i do miss but
other than that you already know look
everybody enjoy your weekend we'll see
you next week a lot of fun stuff in
destiny